mr. Shapiro testify it's not ready
testify before you here today the reason
that I'm with you is that I speak on
dozens of college campuses every year so
I have some first-hand experience with
the anti First Amendment activities that
have been taking places on the college
campuses I've encountered anti-free
speech measures administrative cowardice
even physical violence at campuses
ranging from California State University
in Los Angeles to University of
Wisconsin at Madison which is driving
the legislation that Miss Demings was
talking about that's a Penn State
University to UC Berkeley and I am not
alone in order to understand what's been
going on at some of our college campuses
it's necessary to explore the ideology
that provides the impetus for a lot of
the protesters who violently obstruct
events while fire alarms and solve
professors and even other students and
the impetus for administrators who all
too often humor these protesters free
speech is under assault because of a
three-step argument made by the
advocates and justify errs of violence
the first step is they say that the
validity or invalidity of an argument
can be judged solely by the ethnic
sexual racial or cultural identity of
the person making the argument the
second step is that they claim those who
say otherwise are engaging on what they
call verbal violence and the final step
is they conclude that physical violence
is sometimes justified in order to stop
such verbal violence so let's examine
each of these three steps in turn first
the philosophy of intersectionality this
philosophy now dominates college
campuses as well as a large segment
unfortunately of today's Democratic
Party and suggests that straight white
Americans are inherently the
beneficiaries of white privilege and
therefore cannot speak on certain
policies since they've not experienced
what it's like to be black or Hispanic
or gay or transgender or a woman
this philosophy ranks the value of a
view not based on the logical merit of
the view but on the level of
victimization in American society
experienced by the person espousing the
view therefore if you're an LGBT black
woman your view of American society is
automatically more valuable than that of
a straight white male the next step in
the logic is obvious if a straight white
male or anybody else who ranks lower on
the victimhood scale says something
contrary to the viewpoints of the higher
ranking intersectional intersectionality
identity that person has engaged in a
microaggression as NYU's social
psychologist Jonathan Hite writes
microaggressions are small actions or
word choices that seem on their face to
have no malicious intent
but that our thought of is a kind of
violence nonetheless you don't have to
actively say anything insulting to micro
aggress somebody merely needs to take
offense if for example you say that
society ought to be colorblind your
micro aggressing certain identity groups
who have been victimized by a non
colorblind society note microaggressions
as the name suggests are not merely
insult
they are aggressions they are the
equivalent to physical violence just two
weeks ago psychologist Lisa Feldman
Barrett of Northeastern University
published an essay in the New York Times
suggesting that words should be seen as
physical violence because they can cause
stress and stress causes physical harm
the spellman suggested it is reasonable
scientifically speaking to ban or
restrict speech you do not like at your
school this is both inane and dangerous
that's because it leads to the final
logical step words you don't like
deserve to be fought physically when I
spoke at California State University to
LA one professor threatens students who
sponsored me by offering to fight them
he then posted a slogan on the door of
his office stating the best response to
micro aggression is macro aggression as
height rights this is why the idea that
speech is violence is so dangerous it
tells the members of a generation
already beset by anxiety and depression
that the world is a far more violent and
threatening place than it really is it
tells them that words ideas speakers can
literally kill them even worse at a time
of rapidly rising political polarization
in the United States it helps a small
subset of that generation justify
political violence indeed protesters all
too often engage in physically violent
disruption when they believe their
identity group is under verbal attack by
someone usually conservative but not
always
not only do some administrators look the
other way at Middlebury College Cal
State LA Berkeley evergreen actual
crimes were committed and almost nobody
has been arrested are they actively
forbid events from moving forward
creating a hecklers veto the notion that
if you are physically violent enough you
can get administrators to kowtow to you
to bow before you by cancelling an event
you disagree with altogether all of this
destroys free speech but just as
importantly it turns students into snow
as snowflakes craven and pathetic
looking for an excuse to be offended so
they can earn points in the
intersectionality olympics and then use
those points as a club with which to
beat opponents a healthy nation requires
an emotionally and intellectually
vigorous population ready to engage in
open debate at all times
shields and college students from
opposing viewpoints makes them
simultaneously weaker and more dangerous
we must fight that process at every step
and that begins by acknowledging that
whatever we think about America and
where we stand we must agree on this
fundamental principle all of our views
should be judged on their merits not on
the color or sex or sexual orientation
of the speaker and those use should
never be banned on the grounds that they
offend someone thanks so much mr.
Shapiro you an agitator not as far as
I'm aware so this I think that some of
what's been said does miniskirt for
debate
you know mr. Krishnamoorthy I got it
right when when you were talking about
the Wisconsin law I believe that that
law was brought up in direct indirect
counter to what happened and it was
people talked about on the legislature
I'm for the legislature in direct count
or what happened when I spoke at
University of Wisconsin at Madison where
he had a bunch of protesters who stood
in front of the speech in front of the
stage and obstructed the stage and then
refused to leave and when I asked the
police would they remove the protesters
as they've been going for 15 minutes I
didn't by the way personally two things
just to preface I have no problem
whatsoever with people protesting my
speeches I do have a problem with people
who won't actually let me speak and
number two as far as all the talk about
white supremacy I can speak from
experience
mr. Lawrence your organization named me
the number one target of anti-semitism
online last year so I have I have a
trophy at my house is number one Haiti
Jew in America so I'm and totally
familiar with with the the level of
vitriol bits that you can come in our
politics but one of the things that's a
problem and I think we have to be
careful about is when we say leave it to
the administrators and then the
administrators do what they did at UW
which is they the police I said the
police will you remove these protesters
and the police said we have been told by
the administration that if we remove the
protesters we are to shut down the
events entirely so we can't remove the
protests we literally to wait until they
just got tired and walked out basically
when when that's the response of the
administration shouldn't there be some
sort of repercussion for that because
what I'm seeing is a hecklers veto
that's taking place on campus what I'm
seeing is people who are not engaging in
free speech designed to enrich the
debate but in order to shut down the
debate and there have to be some sort of
ramifications for people who are
actually committing trespass I mean
these are these are the
this is not a question of everyone is
trying to focus in on this on this term
hate crime and hate speech they but the
the important part of those phrases is
not the first word its speech versus
crime so if there's a crime that's being
committed we're all in agreement if
somebody commits a crime and they're
there and they're speaking of an
imminent threat to somebody of course
that's a crime but that is very little
to do with the hate and a lot more to do
with the crime as to whether that's
prosecuted because hate speech is not
prosecutable nor should it be policed by
the campus so the fact is that that what
we are seeing is is a conflation between
speech and active attempts to obstruct
in order to promote the obstruction by
some administrators on a few college
campuses can you speak to how time
manner and place restrictions are being
abused
so most obviously UC Berkeley did that
with Ann Coulter where they kept moving
around her room and they kept saying
that didn't have rooms available they
said the same thing to me a week ago
there's some public outcry now they're
offering some rooms which I you know I
hope that that event goes forward it's
not rare they do this a lot it's a
private university that did it was
DePaul University I was threatened with
arrest if I set foot on campus actually
showed up there and a security guard
told me if I asked him if I moved six
inches forward are you going to arrest
me and he said yes and yet the sheriff
of Cook County behind him so this is a
you know it's it's become a cover for
ideological discrimination because if
Tonique you see coach wants to speak on
these campuses there's not gonna be any
problem the administrators will make
certain that time place and manner
restrictions don't get in the way and
this is why I say you saying that the
discretion of administrators is
wonderful is all well and good except
that they very often are attempting to
achieve a particular political end by
using means that are normally legitimate
and and that's that's definitely a
dangerous thing if you know mind have a
quick note on something that I think it
was mr. Lawrence was saying earlier
about the damage that's done to students
by various things that happen on campus
by threat by by threats of violence and
this sort of thing and obviously
everyone I think agrees that what
happened to Taylor is is unacceptable
but one of the things that I think
should also be pointed as we have a lot
of other students in the in the crowd
and administrators who spend an enormous
amount of time pushing stuff like white
privilege means that you must accept
that you are subordinate in terms of
your view because of identity this also
has some lasting damage
with regard to First Amendment exercise
and with regard to how people perceive
the freedom of the country and I
understand this is universally held
belief among university educators that
we have to accept the the guilt of
particular races or particular sexual
orientations for discrimination that's
happened in the past but when you teach
a bunch of eighteen and nineteen year
old people this you shouldn't be you
shouldn't be surprised when number one
they go into hiding with their viewpoint
or number two they become frustrated
it's an absurdity to suggest that you
can tell people that their viewpoints
are out of line because of their
identity at the same time you're telling
other people that their viewpoints are
completely in line because of their
identity and that any assault on their
senses must be protected or prevented at
any cost
and just like to point out in closing
that the group young americans for
liberty that is handing out
constitutions on campuses all across the
country has changed free speech
restrictions on 25 campuses just by
handing out this document not by setting
fires because they didn't like the
speaker or throwing rocks through
windows but by handing out this
constitution and i am inspired that
there are young people who are inspired
by this document and it should never be
illegal to hand out this document well
said mr. massey real quick miss miss
Roslin is mr. Shapiro's right are most
of the anti speech activities going on
in campuses targeted towards
conservatives and libertarians certainly
the well-publicized ones have been and I
don't I can't speak for campuses across
the country but I go back to an opening
point that I made which was best
summarized in the title of a book by Nat
Hentoff well I just I just wanted to
answer I can't them we'll come back to
that but I just was wanting to respond
mr. Shapiro's point I mean that's my
understanding as well and I'll publish
size incidence and it would be
consistent with what surveys show about
the prevailing beliefs on campus that
the majority of students have are in the
liberal end of the political spectrum
the majority of faculty members are on
the liberal and find that shot doctor so
they would be more likely to engage
rocketed by less irassman you're smiling
you find that talking to don't you now
it's interesting mr. Shapiro you talked
about white
privileged and just this week I had a
conversation with Rachel Lazar who's
done some work a Jewish American woman
who's done some work on this area as
well as having extensive conversations
with dr. Greg parks of Wake Forest
University who's also talked quite a bit
about critical race theory and it's it's
my understanding that white privilege is
not telling individuals that they cannot
speak but it is a term for societal
privilege that individuals have as a
benefit of their white skin and I don't
think that and I think universities
would be remiss to then say that because
you're white you're not allowed to say
anything that's critical of white people
I didn't know that white privilege
actually went into that sphere my
understanding is it's just and the issue
is is that white privilege makes people
uncomfortable to talk about the societal
privilege that they have well it to me
the what I say on campuses all the time
is if you're want to cite instances of
racism that we can all find and fight
together that's something that I am more
than willing to stand next to you and
fight because that's obviously stuff
that we should fight together but when
you just say that there is a white
privilege out there in the ether and
that by dint of birth your skin color
generates for you an advantage what you
are really saying to people is that you
your view is less valuable because you
have not experienced what I've
experienced and that is an identity
argument that's a character argument
that's not a rational political argument
they can actually be be taken on in
anyway that's that's it's more of as
more of a cudgel and a club than it is
an attempt to open a discussion well I
think it's a demonstrable evidence that
through society's demographics so that
being white has societal privileges that
being black does not but I we I'm also
interested in what you just said now is
that you would stand next to anyone who
has this so mr. Shapiro my question to
you is for Miss miss dumps tone the
tying the noose around the campus and
writing messages that target
african-american young students would
you consider that hate speech in them
would you
dan next to her and fight for her as I
say is the first I'm hearing about it
honestly but really what yeah but but
from from hearing about it maybe because
it's local and I'm from LA but in any
case um I'm more than happy more than
happy to stand alongside her and and
fight whatever group was responsible for
this know not only more than happy I
mean you're talking about the alright
again I was the number one target of an
systematic irassman from the alt-right
last year I'm more than happy to do all
that night I think there's one more
distinction that has to be made when we
talk about cases like like Taylor's
they're horrific and the administration
is siding with Taylor the administration
is doing the right thing by Taylor or
trying to do the right thing
by Taylor as they should be and I think
that we need to make a distinction
between cases where the administration
is actively participating in the
suppression of speech in cases in which
the administration is trying to do the
right thing as is in order to in order
to make people in order to punish people
for application of crime the gentle